our scripture that I Luke 16:10 whoever
can be trusted with very little can also
be trusted with much and whoever is
dishonest but very little will also be
dishonest with much I was working for a
guy one time who taught me something I
never thought of it because I hate
paying taxes so badly I just I hate it
because the government is so out of
control they take too much of the money
that we earn and you know just basically
wasted right so I just hate the whole
concept it's just it just infuriates me
and I was in my early 20s just out of
college working for a guy and he said
you never ever ever ever ever ever cheat
on your taxes and I said well I don't
know why and he said the rest of your
life never cheat on your taxes and I
said well I wasn't planning on it beau
why and he said because it doesn't say
anything about the government it says
something about you it's your integrity
and it wasn't long after that I was
trying I was looking this business to
buy and the guy is telling me how well
the business actually makes more money
but I don't report it all on my taxes
and I'm thinking to myself if he'll a
lot of the government in order to save
money
why wouldn't he lie to me buying the
business from him in order to get more
money because integrity is integrity
right but the government's different now
I mean the government isn't different
the government is different but you're
not you're still the same guy who lied
just five minutes ago and admitted it
and told me how detailed you are about
your lying and then I'm supposed to
trust you and the numbers that you're
giving me on your business see it
doesn't say of anything by the
government when you cheat on your taxes
it says something about you it doesn't
say anything when you cheat some big
company because they can afford to take
the hit
you steal from your employer because
they can afford it and you're just a
little guy oh brother all that says is
you really are the little guy no
integrity you're a thief
didn't say anything about your company
didn't say anything about the person you
stole from it says something about you
whoever can be trusted with very little
can also be trusted with much and
whoever is dishonest with very little
will also be dishonest with much hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]